[Music]
now let's move on to some more couples
news first Beyonce and jay-z who's
opening up on how the couple got past
his cheating scandal I have a beautiful
wife who was understanding and knew that
I'm not the worst of what I've done and
like did the hard work of going to
therapy and we love each other right so
we really put in the work
jay-z was on david letterman's my next
guest needs no introduction the 70 year
old host also addressed his own
infidelity back in 2009 six months into
his marriage with Regina Lasko Dave
admitted to having premarital affairs
with coworkers I did something that I
had no business with and I regret it and
since then I have tried to acknowledge
that mistake and be a better person at
the time the pain that I caused myself
was the fear that I had blown up my
family it's as scared as I've ever been
in my life yeah like you I like to
believe that we're in a better place
today I'm proud of the father and the
husband that I am today because of all
the work that was done
[Music]
[Applause]